var1 interesting interview there with
Jared Kushner another point that he made
was that the Palestinians had been lied
to for a long time and that's why their
expectations were just too high in here
he is saying you know this is achievable
and he talks about a future Palestinian
state from what you've seen of the deal
what would this future Palestinian state
the Jared Kushner is talking about
actually look like you know generally
speaking we say the devil is in the
details in this case that that that the
devil is in fact in the headlines and
the headline is has just been mentioned
by Jared Kushner which is kind of
amazing when you think of it here you
have the author of a peace deal who is
by definition of fanatic Zionist
supporter of the illegal Israeli
settlement and yet he projects himself
as some kind of a mediator who has the
Palestinians best interest in mind it is
so realistic in every possible way
obnoxious in every possible term but Mia
as it may what he just described the
bypass roads and the tunnels and all of
that that is the definition of apartheid
that is apartheid that's what we had
when we divided the Palestinian
territories occupied territories into
ABC and h1 and h2 and Israel created
bypass roads and they created an
industrial zones for the Israelis where
Palestinian cheap labor will work
these are Bandar stands he's recreating
the South African model of apartheid in
Palestine and calling it a state there
is no state because already Prime
Minister Netanyahu is and has declared
at the White House that he will be
annexing much of Area C which means all
of the areas and include the settlements
plus the Jordan River that in in and by
itself almost half of the West Bank and
that's done today with the blessing of
the American president now you say that
they've been lied to
of course they've been made the
Palestinians have been made promise
after promise after promise since 1991
and most of the promises not come
through so we all remember everything
everything from the Carter plan to the
Reagan plan to the Clinton plan to the
George George Bush plan and roadmap and
so on so forth but yes none of them come
through and that's why the Palestinians
when they look at the Trump plan they
think it's destiny is the same like the
bush plan and the Reagan plan and that
is the dustbin of history
I mean who remembers the Bush plan who
remembers the Reagan plan who will
remember the Trump plan three four years
down the road that doesn't mean the
situation's getting any better for the
Palestinians yeah in a way that we have
seen a difference because I believe it's
about two years isn't it since the move
of the US Embassy to Jerusalem from Tel
Aviv that the Palestine have actually
backed away not seeing the u.s. as even
trying to be impartial in the issue so
if the u.s. is no longer a partial
arbiter in this then who do you think at
this moment from the international
community could come up would come up to
I guess you know make their voices heard
and and perhaps help find a different
kind of solution and the one on the
plate from the Americans what the short
answer is no one because the United
States already made it it's exclusive
area of influence on Authority no one is
allowed in the world including Russia
Europe China and who or whoever is
allowed to intervene in Israel Palestine
except the United States but just to
emphasize that point about about you
know being a fair or not fair sponsor of
the talks and so on and so forth look
the Americans were never fair mediators
between Israelis and Palestinians Israel
and America are best allies they have
the most special of all special
relationships and they've never denied
it the United States always stood behind
Israel supported Israel and in fact as
one of the American negotiator put it
the United States was always Israel's
lawyer
in the negotiations were the
Palestinians but at least it gave
appearance of talking to the
Palestinians engaging the Palestinians
listening to the Palestinians but this
Trump administration has basically wrote
off the Palestinians imposed unilateral
measures on the Palestinians and in
Palestine and in Jerusalem and in as far
as a settlement concerned with zero
consultants with the Palestinians the
the Trump administration is simply
imposing one dictator after another like
that including lest everyone anyone
forgets the closure of the PLO office in
Washington cutting it to honor war
cutting aid to the Palestinians moving
the embassy to Jerusalem also so forth
without any consultation of the
Palestinians and now we have all just
seen the celebration at the White House
the bride the bride's father the dowry
everything is ready except there is no
groom the Palestinians are not invited
the Palestinians are not consulted the
Palestinians don't wanna have anything
to do with this wedding they with this
celebration because their entire
existence as people as sovereignty as
Independence as statehood as refugees
has been dismissed by the Trump
administration Bashara senior political
analyst marma will of course cross back
to you for more analysis for the moment
thank you